What is a line?
It is basically a thin straight mark
made by a pencil or a marker
and it extends indefinitely in both directions.
But I can also draw a line like this or like this.
It means that we do not have a single way in which a line can be drawn.
We just draw a part of a line.
Lines are generally named with lowercase letters.
This can be called line 'p',
or we can draw a line like this and mark two points 'A and B'.
This will be called line 'AB'.
Line 'AB' can also be written as 'AB' with a tiny line drawn over 'AB'.
So what is a ray?
A ray starts at one point and goes on indefinitely in one direction.
Just like for lines even rays can be drawn in different ways.
What we draw is just a part of a ray.
We can mark this point as 'A',
and mark a point 'B' somewhere on the ray!
We can call this ray 'AB'.
Or write 'AB' with a tiny ray over it.
This tells us that the ray starts at point 'A'.
and goes indefinitely in one direction.
It's a bit ironical.
But the point at which the rate begins is called the end point of the Ray.
Here, 'A' is the end point of this ray!
Which means it cannot be written as ray 'BA'.
Or 'BA' with a tiny ray over it.
But line 'AB' can also be written as line 'BA'.
We just need to be careful when we are dealing with a ray.
Now let's get to the final concept in this video.
Look at what we have drawn here.
We can see that it has two end points.
This is called a line segment, and it is a fixed part of a line.
This is its specified length,
and it does not extend indefinitely in any direction.
If the end points are 'A' and 'B'. This can be called line segment 'AB'.
Or it can also be written as 'AB' with a line segment over it.
And yes, we can also write this as 'BA' with a line segment over it.
A line extends indefinitely in both directions.
A ray starts at its end point .
And goes indefinitely in one direction .
And a line segment is a fixed part of a line.